-My first guest
is a talented actor
who stars in the new movie
"Wild Mountain Thyme,"
which is in theaters and
On Demand December 11th.
Here is Jamie Dornan.
Hey, bud!
Oh, it's good to see you, pal.
-Good to see you, too, man.
-I know, crazy circumstances,
but how are you
and your family doing?
I know you have three daughters
under the age of 8, right?
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
And you have two around
that same age, right?
-Yep. And what has
the past nine months
been like with three kids?
-I think it's kind of --
It's been all-encompassing.
You know, it's kind of been
the agony and the ecstasy,
like, in the same
period of time.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Some of the most
challenging days
I've ever had as a parent,
as we've ever had as parents.
And then some of the most fun
to spend all this time together.
You know, kids are amazing,
'cause they truly live
in the moment.
So they're not concerned
about what's happening
and why the world
is the way it is at this age.
You know, they're just,
"This is what we have now.
Let's have fun."
So, like, that's a great thing
to be around, you know?
-I saw you took the plunge
and rejoined Instagram
in quarantine.
Tell me about
your first post here.
What is going on here?
What happened to you?
-I mean, it looks like
I'm the most committed
actor ever auditioning
for Blue Man Group.
-[ Laughs ]
-I knew that was you!
I knew that was you.
You ignored me.
I go, "Jamie, hello.
We have a thing,"
and you're just like
real quiet, and...
With your turtleneck,
and you walked off the stage.
-[ Laughs ]
-What was happening there?
-What's actually happening is,
I had to get this
full body cast -- or, upper body
cast and head cast made
for a job, which I was about
to start shooting
when the pandemic hit,
and actually,
I'm not able
to shoot that anymore
'cause of schedules,
so someone else
is now playing that character.
'Cause that is a hellish
experience, doing that.
I don't know if you've had that
done, but it's really,
really uncomfortable,
and I'm not a panicky person,
but I had a full panic attack.
Because I'm not a great
nose breather anyway,
but they put, like,
two little holes in your nose,
and that was the only way
I could breathe.
So, I was really struggling,
and it's like 45 minutes.
But I've been told that
if I ever
have to do it again
for anything,
I won't have to
'cause they have my cast now.
So it's the only time
I ever have to do it in my life.
-Yeah, it's currently
a mannequin at Macy's.
It's in the front window.
Congratulations.
-I'm delighted.
-I did that for "SNL,"
where they did the thing,
but it didn't take 45 minutes.
They just -- I just did
a face thing, though, too.
But, actually, you know,
I have such a big Irish face
that it did take 45 minutes
and extra plaster.
[ Both laugh ]
They go, "Gosh, you have
a really big head."
What else have you taken up
in quarantine?
Have you had time to focus on
any hobbies or any new talents?
-You know, like everybody,
I thought,
"How can I use this time
to the best of my ability
when I have so much of it?"
and I -- you know,
I signed up for, like, a
fast-learning harmonica course.
I -- You know,
it was one of those things,
it's on the side of your e-mail,
your inbox, and it's like,
"Learn harmonica -- in three
weeks, you'll be an expert."
And instead of $179,
it's like $46 or something,
so I was like, "Yeah, okay."
-That's a deal.
-Haven't played once.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
You didn't even do one lesson?
-In fact, I didn't even
open the trial, no.
-[ Laughs ]
-No.
But, look, I have it.
-You had the intention.
Oh, you have
the harmonica there!
-Yeah.
-Oh, my good--
It's fairly simple. You could
probably figure it out.
♪♪
I think you should start
teaching the lessons.
I know that song.
Of course.
-Should I take that on the road,
like a one-man show,
like Dick Van Dyke?
-If you don't, I think you're
wasting a lot of -- yeah.
That's a big opportunity there
that you should take.
I think, let's go back
to talking about your acting.
I was so excited
about this movie,
because I love
romantic comedies.
I'm Irish, I think Irelanders
are just so gorgeous
and beautiful.
It's called
"Wild Mountain Thyme" --
T-H-Y-M-E,
and it was filmed in Ireland,
set not too far
from where you grew up.
Is that true?
-Yeah.
I mean, it's based
on John Patrick Shanley,
who wrote directed our movie.
He did a play on Broadway called
"Outside Mullingar."
Mullingar is in County Meath,
which is --
Yeah, I'm from County Down.
It's probably 200 miles
from where I grew up,
so not a million miles away.
Yeah, and it's a strange story.
I don't know if you're familiar
with Shanley's movies
and the way he writes,
but they're quite heightened,
fantastical kind of worlds.
And this is almost like a fairy
tale, like a fable, you know?
It's very romantic,
but it's kind of otherworldly,
and Emily Blunt and I play these
two quite disconnected,
quite strange Irish farmers
who are sort of
destined to be together
but can't work out a way
to be together.
But, yeah,
that's kind of it in a nutshell.
-It's a great cast.
It's you, Emily Blunt
as your love interest.
Jon Hamm, who is just a friend,
and just, gosh,
we love him here.
Christopher Walken, who is --
Luckily, I got to work
with that guy,
I think, four times on "SNL,"
on "Saturday Night Live."
He plays your father.
Isn't he the most fun,
interesting guy?
-Yeah.
But also, you know,
he's Christopher Walken.
I mean, it literally
doesn't get more kind of
iconic, I don't think,
in our game.
-Yeah.
-He's, as you know well,
he's actually just, like,
the sweetest guy in the world.
He's really -- and he's played
so many sinister characters
and so many weighted, heavy,
sort of frightening characters,
and he's, like,
the sweetest dude.
He was, like, really,
just very connected and calm.
-He's a great dancer.
-Amazing.
I mean, on top of acting,
he can do everything, yeah.
After you talked with him
for a while,
do you find yourself starting
to lean into the impression
a little bit
when you talk to him?
-Dude, I think it's, like,
the sort of --
You know, it's like
the equivalent of having
to sit on your hands
so that you don't start
to gesture him
or start to, like, mimic him.
I'm not a brilliant mimic.
You are.
I wouldn't say
I'm a great mimic,
but everyone
has a Christopher Walken.
Like, everyone has one.
So you're sort of really
pushing yourself not to do it.
Because imagine how many times
people do it to him, you know?
It's bad.
And, actually, I think
you realize in person,
like, it's more --
You know, the impressions just
become their own thing
that they're way more
pushed than the reality.
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
But, I mean, I find myself --
I do it all the time
even just interviewing --
even you, I find myself
thinking I can do
a pretty good Irish accent.
-Yeah.
-My key to the Irish accent,
for me --
I would never attempt one --
but I just keep
saying the word "Em."
Em, em, em, em, em, em...
And that's all you keep saying.
-That can get you pretty far.
That can get you, like,
a good night out in a pub.
You can just get by
with just saying that.
-I should learn
how to play harmonica.
I shouldn't even
think about acting.
But I heard Emily Blunt
introduced you
to something you call
"acting juice" on the set.
What's acting juice?
-So, I actually don't even know
the brand name, and I should,
because if I start
telling people,
then they'll send me a load
of it, and I'll be delighted.
-[ Laughs ]
-But she had just done
this movie, "Jungle Cruise,"
with Dwayne Johnson,
and I guess when Johnson
got her on to this,
it's like an energy drink,
and so she had loads of it
with her in Ireland.
Like, she'd had it shipped over.
She's like,
"Do you want to try one?"
And that was
just this fateful day
that I tried
this great-flavored juice.
And it is like --
I don't know.
It's like Red Bull times 10
but apparently
not as bad for you.
And it just gives you --
Makes you feel like
you're kind of maybe
about to have a heart attack,
what I imagine that feels like.
-That's the slogan.
That's the slogan
for the energy drink.
-[ Laughing ]
-"If you drink this,
you'll feel like..."
-Unique selling point.
-"...you might
have a heart attack," yeah.
-You feel like
you're having a heart attack,
but you're okay, you won't.
-Yeah, "Legally,
you can't sue us."
-That sort of sustains
for a while.
But it just got to the point
where Emily and I
convinced ourselves
that we sort of couldn't act
without this stuff,
so we were just calling it
"acting juice"
and we'd be really panicking
if they were like,
"Okay. Guys, we're gonna shoot
in about five minutes.
You ready for that scene?"
And we'd be like, "Yeah, yeah,"
and then be like...
"Are we ready? There's no
acting juice anywhere!"
-"I don't know
what to do anymore!
I need the acting juice!"
-Honestly, it was --
Luckily, I've done a movie since
and I didn't have
any acting juice,
and it all went okay, so I don't
think I'm reliant on it.
-Yeah, you still got the chops.
And, gosh, the chemistry
between you guys was perfect.
So, whatever it was, it worked.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Jamie Dornan
and Emily Blunt
in "Wild Mountain Thyme."
Take a look.
-Anthony!
Oh!
-[ Laughing ]
Are you all right?
-I'm fine.
-What are you doing out there?
-Fishing.
-That was fishing?
-Yeah.
-Without your rod?
Who were you talking to?
-Wasn't talking.
-Looked to be talking, then
swatting, then you jumped in.
-I did not.
It's the Kellys that jump in.
I'm a Reilly.
-You're a Reilly.
-What are you doing
down by the river?
-What I've been doing --
after this one.
-Well, you're not still
from the night before?
-I am.
-Good God in haven,
you look the worst for it.
-Well, thanks so much.
You don't look perfect yourself.